day of high stakes diplomacy in
washington and moscow failed to break
the deadline deadlock rather over
ukraine russian president vladimir putin
met with french president emmanuel
macron in moscow yesterday while
president biden met with germany's new
chancellor at the white house mr biden
warned that a crucial natural gas
pipeline from russia to germany would
not be allowed to open if russian forces
invade ukraine ed o'keefe has more from
the white house on this part of the
story ed good morning to you good
morning gail good to see you the
american president the german chancellor
warned of severe consequences if russia
invades ukraine and they tried putting
on a united front amid concerns that
germany isn't being strong enough
against russia
with u.s forces now deploying into
eastern europe ahead of a potential
invasion president biden is warning
americans in ukraine to get out i hate
to see them get caught in a crossfire he
made the comments alongside german
chancellor olaf scholes as they insist
their countries agree about the
consequences of vladimir putin invading
ukraine and you'd pay a heavy price but
germany is being less aggressive than
other nato allies in warning russia a
major sticking point nordstream 2 a more
than 750 mile natural gas pipeline being
built between germany and russia europe
relies on russia for a third of its gas
supply and once the pipeline's
operational it's estimated tens of
billions of dollars in gas revenue will
flow back into russia
yet mr biden warns that won't happen if
russia invades there will be no longer a
north stream too
we will bring an end to it
at least 70 percent of russian troops
needed for a full-scale land invasion
are in place well north of a hundred
thousand and it continues to grow
[Music]
in moscow
putin met with french president emmanuel
macron for more than five hours the
russian president indicated he's
prepared to continue negotiations to
possibly head off a full-on war with
ukraine and said discussion with macron
could create a foundation for our
further steps
[Music]
after his meeting with macron putin once
again denied that he has any plans to
invade ukraine but he also said he looks
forward to speaking with macron later
today after the french president meets
with ukrainian leaders in kiev
nate
ed thank you